[Laughter]
i brought some shot glass i hear you
don't drink uh you don't drink beer i
drink not not usually i like a cider
every now and then i'm not i'm a wine
girl you're from texas and you don't
drink beer i know and here's the thing
doesn't this personality scream beer i
exude like she likes i never thought
that when i first saw you i didn't go
like honey the beer girls then you
didn't see me properly
my friends are more shocked than anyone
have you ever done a beer commercial no
i wouldn't no would you do a beer
commercial how much am i being paid
a lot i can drink beer for money this is
a sparkling white okay sparkling wine
sparkling white uh
it's from spain
lovely love espana yep
so culture i don't know what you're
talking about
yeah we'll move on to the red in a bit
okay okay i like it get the first we
should have had like a charcuterie board
or something in a hole like this
ellen never does this
no we both love wine and food you are if
we do right and wine probably too much
is there too much i don't know it's not
like i would do it while i was being
interviewed
not during the day before
not in front of a group of people no
why would i do that i have no i don't
have a problem you're fine i'm fine
everyone's fine
um
i need to ask you though welcome back to
everyone's fine with kelly clarkson
that's my new book um i need to ask you
about this video joel can you joe can
you roll this footage
what's happening here all right so that
uh that's thanksgiving that's a turkey
actually is that stuffing in the turkey
okay
all right so uh there's a there's a
butcher shop here called mccall's
meeting fish and this amazing butcher
named megan decided she would take an
entire turkey before it was cooked take
all the meat off and the skin
wrap it all back in the skin with the
stuffing and you put that in the oven
and you roast it for two and a half
hours and it comes out looking like you
cooked an alien but it is here's the
thing it looks like something i want to
eat right now so i'm into it uh did you
bring one did you see how juicy that all
right it was very moist it was exactly
how it was
i got two of them uh we have 20 or 30
people over for thanksgiving oh my gosh
she's a big family yeah no and they they
just like free stuff and so
they all come down from seattle and they
stay with us 10 like 11 people stay in
the house and i cook and so does my wife
and and then we we have this huge dinner
and then i resent my family for six
months
all right something else i know um that
you love is your dog
your dog is always on instagram is it a
beanbag i don't have any dogs you have a
dog yeah i have three dogs yeah so a
bean bag the dog wait you have three
dogs why do you only i don't i only see
the one uh bean bag is the yeah that's
he's he's crazy
i like honestly oh and he's attacking me
that's a normal morning uh he's a very
excitable um french bulldog if you could
there's no audio there which is really
taking away from it we make a lot of
silent films as you can see uh
and uh he he's one of those morning
kisses tore my shirt off earlier so uh
yeah he's insane and we have these two
other dogs that get no press uh because
they're well there he is again there
that's how oh they're more that's cowboy
and harry and they're just miserable
because as
all the time the and that there he is
maniac
no but you don't have any cats though
right
no i love cats i'm allergic my wife is
horribly alone
but uh after because the bean bag and
cowboy have fur not hair yeah having
been around them for so long she figured
out that she basically lost her
uh allergy to cats and so now i'm like
we have switched floodgates uh i need to
get some cats fine bring out the cats oh
that is not what i mean
damn it
oh my god
oh
[Applause]
guys these are actual cats they're
actually little kittens this is y'all
all these kittens are brothers and
sisters from the same litter the black
and white ones are named spatzle
buccatini and zit ziti and the orange
ones are orzo ravioli and bigelow
somebody likes pasta
sorry
and those are all different types of
sushi
they're going to hang out with us though
for a bit and by the end of the show
maybe joel will adopt one yeah or he
might do the smart thing and wait for
his wife's okay
i'm gonna adopt two and then i'll get a
divorce because my wife will be like
what the [ __ ] is going on so
if anyone else wants to adopt these
kittens you could visit them at paul
works adoption center and come on
they're mine they're my cats
i mean these kittens are famous as well
okay a super girl the dog okay they've
been on tv you're gonna look at their
faces
my husband is so nervous right now yeah
i don't even care that i'm allergic i'll
take a pill or something or a shot you
gotta push that cat across the table
like you're putting in a bet playing
tennis
i'll raise you two cats how much do you
like cuddles right
speaking of work though um you're super
talented
you've got two films at the tribeca film
festival right now right yeah one's
called i found a kitty and
you know it's called hey look a squirrel
i'm a kitty yeah
uh yes i do i'm you know because it's at
a film festival so you'll all see it uh
and
won't be distracted at all
by
by the cat olympics happening on
let's just you know what let's just let
them go
enjoy
enjoy yourselves just go
wait they can't hurt themselves right if
they come off of the don't all cats land
on your feet or some or their feet okay
no no no what are you talking about no
i've heard this if a cat like falls or
something they so the cat falls they
land on their feet oh my god it's on the
back i'm a mom i'm a mom you gotta get
it you gotta get it you gotta get it
gonna be fine it's gonna
this is how they learn
this is how they learn
oh i've gotta get you i've gotta give
you anyway i see you guys are very
excited about my films
[Applause]
this
is all right look i mean have you ever
seen they're set up they're set up this
guy better fall in line all right go
over there oh you're cr you are a
crawler oh you're going all the way
around
so about your films
this that guy you're crazy i don't want
you to die man okay
so about your films i don't know
happily becky and happily yes becky is
made by uh it's a great uh it's me and a
wonderful actress named lulu wilson and
kevin james
uh
it is
it is definitely not a comedy and then
uh the other one's called happily uh
directed by a guy named ben david
grobinski and it's been a wonderful
actor named uh carrie boucher and steven
root who you've seen on barry and a
thousand other things radio and uh but
no one's listened to a thing i've said
it doesn't matter let's get all the cats
let's just move on to the red and let's
see what happens it's fine it's fine
it's fine take a sip oh wait that's mine
that's
that's yeah
yeah you're just kidding
it's just like natural that's fine
that's fine okay so that will come out
yeah that's in april and i know you'll
all go to the film festival you're gonna
love it
all right it's fine it's fine it's a cat
wait okay wait joel so card sharks car
sharks is back look um do you like being
a game host is it fun what is a game
host a game you're hosting a game i
think it's in the definition isn't the
name i think it's game show uh
the game show host a game show we give
away cats and uh please don't die it's
gonna go great uh yeah you can win look
yes it's you can win a lot of money i
can get i can totally get you on the
show yeah okay uh but if you think about
it kelly nobody has listened to a thing
we have said
in the last
few minutes well be sure to catch all
the things
watch car sharks miss somewhere on abc
who cares
we're having fun also he has the film's
becky and happily coming out but we'll
be right back with empire's grace buyers
also known as the villainous ex-wife of
lucious lions stay with us
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going